ten days from now it's Christmas I was
just wondering who few will go to church
when it's Christmas oh that's a lot why
what else okay Dave Newton go to the
observatory ii-i'll go to I'll go to a
Christmas service because at Christmas
for me I celebrate Christmas and best
summarize the reasons best summarized in
one line from John's Gospel and the
light shines in the darkness and
darkness cannot overcome it now that the
light shines in darkness that seems to
me a very interesting concept of
obviously people will contest whether
Christ is the light I believe Christ is
the light but this idea that something
good is inserted in a situation in which
is compromised which is canard that
seems to me significant but I think I
actually like the second line of this of
the saying and the darkness cannot
overcome and for me Christmas is a
celebration of kind of primordial nature
of the good we discussed earlier this
morning about the primacy of good and
the place of evil weakness of strength
of evil I believe that good is primary
its primordial in fact so that evil is
always distortion of the good and that
the victory is there already existence
itself is good and this existence our
existence itself we celebrate and we
start from there and that's also why I
believe that it's goodness that
overcomes
the evil and that the evil cannot be
always only be overcome within the moral
frame
why should I stay you're not going for
two reasons two reasons one reason is
that in Russia we have two calendars one
there yeah yeah the thing is that now
first we have the Western Christmas than
the New Year than the Russian Christmas
than Russian New Year so it's kind of
stupid to to mix them together so what
do you celebrate when you go let's say
and the 25th right when it's old or
older Russian or I mean secular Russian
or Western Christmas when the real
Christmas will happen later religious
Christmas so it is particularly
important one one thing that's that's
crazy
by itself but the other reason is more
mysterious and deep the thing is that
Russians including me they celebrate
Easter because it is a mystery to be
born it's nothing
everyone is born but to be resurrected
oh my goodness
finally
okay why I'm not going to church I you
know it's my church ISM in my spirit and
it's a it's it's it's in my spirituality
and I don't need to go to a building or
an edifice although I love the Gothic
cathedral and I love basilica's in Italy
and the acoustics and all of that but
one thing that we've missed in this
conversation is biology and another
thing that we've missed is really
talking about evylyn we will be
discussed evil and politics and I think
beautifully in in some of the the
stories that that you told especially
with the film and mike and and hear in
your experiences in Syria and Russia and
everything that goes on but we must
realize that we are human physical
biological agents we have agency we as
sentient and we must forgive certain
elements of evil because if we don't
have oxytocin the chemical emitted in
our neurological framework we can't feel
joy or happiness and 5% of the
population does not have the genetic
makeup to produce oxytocin and are those
people evil because they can't produce
oxytocin know that it can't be really
detected and if you look at the prisons
eighty percent of people in prison can't
produce oxytocin not because of a
genetic deficiency but because they
didn't learn how to build the neural
pathways when they were children because
they didn't get nurturing so it's a new
way to look at evil is maybe not the
dark side and maybe horrible horrific
people but to also have some compassion
that if someone cannot feel joy or
happiness or love which is to me better
than good see you know the equivalent
opposite of evil there is nothing like
love and generosity the reason that I
wanted to to have this discussion
on Christmas he said the ideal is there
is also something like a cosmic war yeah
which is synthesizing star wars and then
let the force be with you but there was
a force of evil metaphysical voters the
Inca told the story about it and then
the idea at least in Christianity there
was also a redeemer and there is
redemption which has nothing to do with
biological issues and I want to
understand a middle of it you probably
can help what is the meaning of this
idea that a cosmic power of goodness has
been incarnated and left on earth
because that's what Christmas is all
about that's what I want to suggest with
this idea of light coming into the
darkness and when we when we think about
God we generally think of God in
association with the phrase God Almighty
and then the power ends up being the
most significant feature characteristic
of God but actually in in in many
traditions certainly in Christian
tradition sense of God's love is more
fundamental in a sense God's divinity
lies in God's love indeed in Christian
tradition in God's unconditional love
that consequence of that is the
relationship between God of the world is
that a world being held in God's hands
world being a place where God's goodness
can come become manifest and therefore
there is also struggle against the evil
that appears in the world going to
church on Christmas is trying to be
receptive to a message of humility I
think this is the main message of
Christmas to me and humility is is an
ocean very tied with everything we've
been discussing because it's the
antidote so to speak for the against the
arrogance of power
yes the arrogance of wealth we are we
the arrogance of science if I may of
scientism and the arrogance of identity
politics Leon what is the Jewish
perspective on retention on Redemption
well I side with the rabbi in the Talmud
who says may the Messiah come and may I
never live to see him I you know that
the history of the history of messianism
in Judaism is the history of false
messianism we are a strange people in
this way we didn't think people believe
we invented the idea of the Messiah
that's not true but the really precise
way and I've made I'm actually in the
middle of allegedly of a book on this
subject I've studied the Messianic
traditions of Judaism in great detail
and it would be more precise to say that
we invented the idea of the Messiah and
the simultaneous reluctance to accept
one that there is a kind of skepticism
about Redemption when I hear my brother
costume talk about what he imagines the
end end of days to be I must say I feel
nothing but Envy I wish I could believe
such things not criticism but Envy all
my life I was moved by the story of
Jesus but only in the way that I was
moved by a profound human story it is an
exclusively human story for me you have
to have a heart of stone not to be moved
by it but it has no philosophical or
metaphysical or religious implications
for me and the Incarnation is a you know
the idea that good came into the world
and so on the Incarnation makes no sense
to a to a stiff-necked Jew such as
myself but I you know but because I come
from a tradition in which good and evil
come into the world every time a baby is
born that is to say that there is evil
and goodness in every human heart there
is a yetzer hatov innate yetzer hara and
that is that is how evil and good and
we'll subsist in the world but there is
if you ask me what Christmas means to me
I'll tell you a story for many many
decades there was a vigil a Christian
vigil outside the South African embassy
in Washington protesting apartheid and
one day it was in the early 80s I got a
call from a Christian friend who was
responsible for the vigil and he said I
have a kind of strange request
you know we don't want we want to keep
this vigil everyday even to pause it for
one day would be a great defeat and it's
a week it's a week from Christmas and I
said I get it send the Christians home
the Jews will take over the vigil and
that's how we celebrated Christmas with
all that that implies
[Applause]
you